we had this follow and uh
he um
he criticized the scientific method that
we have here he doesn't like it and he
went over different aspects of it and
we're going to answer some of his
inquiries his questions right
and here's one okay this is what he said
he was talking about whether science is
about uh studying
and whether science has to do with
knowledge
and whether um
you test the hypothesis as we covered
the other day but then whether um you
know these uh these uh science is is
about getting a degree
is is that what science is about
studying getting a degree collecting
knowledge and learning from our mistakes
is that what it is is science an ongoing
process okay and here's what he's had to
say his own words okay so here it is pay
attention give me a second here
here it goes
the questions and issues addressed in
this rebuttal include
is science about learning by rote
is science about accumulating knowledge
and does science progress through trial
and error
to graduate you need to show that you
have an understanding of what you have
been taught now to answer the question
of what happens if you obtain no
knowledge well that's a tricky one
because you should obtain at least a
tiny amount of knowledge even if the
knowledge that is obtained is the thing
you are doing isn't working
there is still some knowledge yeah it
may not necessarily be the knowledge
that you're after but science is all
about trial and error if something
doesn't work well you now know that it
doesn't work so go back to the drawing
board and try something different it is
very difficult for me to think of a
scenario in which you wouldn't actually
gain any knowledge unless of course
you're doing absolutely terrible science
terrible science yeah i agree with them
you know terrible science what is
terrible science well let's find out uh
i don't know where this fellow studied
maybe studied at harvard or cambridge
one of those monasteries and maybe he
was a choir boy he was required to
memorize everything that was fed to him
and that's what he regurgitated let's
find out what terrible science is okay
so he says terrorist of all sciences or
you know what we say here terrible
science is what he mentioned there
graduates uh must show that they um can
regurgitate what they memorize by wrote
from the previous generation
is that what science is you sit down you
open a book you memorize what's in the
book which is what people from the
previous generation wrote you memorize
it regurgitate it for the test get a
degree
that's science
studying memorizing is that how science
progresses is that what he calls
studying
just memorizing
science he says uh is knowledge we say
it's got nothing to do with knowledge
now people raise the um issue the
argument that that's what it's always
been the word science comes from uh the
uh
latin meaning
syria meaning knowledge
and the question is uh first of all
etymology has uh you know
we don't use that in science because
that's just history that's just you know
the origin of a word you know they could
have misty find it from the start
okay that's one issue the other one is
that you know we change definitions
whenever we find something wrong with
them over the ages we don't rely on
history and say that's that's what
science was from the beginning and
that's how we have to keep it today in
fact uh in the 17th century they changed
the notion of science which they called
natural philosophy and they said look
there was a problem with with the greeks
uh-huh what was the problem well the
problem was that they didn't run
experiments to test their hypothesis
okay so so the greeks did not test the
hypothesis and so they changed the
notion of science they say no
science you need to introduce
experiments and you have to emphasize
math you need to have equations and so
on and so they changed the the direction
of science in the direction of math and
what they did was describe the
experiments that they ran and come up
with an equation and they say okay
that's science science is an equation
that describes
uh how something occurred meaning what
happened but only a description of it
mathematica a quantitative description
of it and today to this day we have no
explanations
that's the problem okay we have no
rational explanations for any phenomenon
especially that's invisible intangible
okay that's that's where we're at so it
doesn't matter that the etymology takes
you back to the word syria which is
knowledge if
we redefine words when we find something
wrong with them
and the question is whether knowledge
has anything to do with science and no
knowledge when you know something you
believe it
the other guy believes something
different you believe that god exists
you know god exists the other guy knows
that god doesn't exist so who's right
which one is the fact again you know if
everybody knows things which are
opposites contradictory and then no we
don't
do trial and error in science
essentially we have to explain something
you can do all the trial and error you
want in your dark basement when you come
to the conference we need for you to
explain what you learned
what your conclusions are from from your
experiments but to do an experiment
anybody can do an experiment here i'll
do an experiment which i always do here
very important experiment i let go of
the pencil okay and it falls to earth
there's your experiment let's do it
twice so it's repeatable so it's
scientific right there it goes again
okay now i did the experiment was that
science
what did i learn that a pencil follows
we call that science doing experiments
and describing it quantitatively like
you know what the uh acceleration of
gravity is what what rate it fell
is that science you know that's like
saying i measure a table measured one
meter one meter and one millimeter
because i measured it more precisely
and you get a nobel prize for that you
because you measured something and put
it into an equation is that science
so no uh science is not by trial and
error technology which is by trial and
error we do not do experiments in
science what we do in science we explain
experiments how they happen what would
cause them to happen that's what we do
in science but we don't do experiments
the experiments what the technician or
you know the operator does he he goes
and does the experiment brings the data
back to the engineer or to the
scientists and that's the guy that's
gonna figure out how it happened or you
know what actually happened but to do an
experiment it's not science you go to
the lab you mix two liquids it was blue
now it turns red
you don't understand why
but you did the experiment
and you can see how it rated when you
know so many seconds it turned you know
red or blue or whatever
is that science
just you know it's what uh ernest
rutherford called uh stamp collecting
science is not stamp collecting you
don't just collect data and bring it in
and say i did science because i did an
experiment and collected all this data
and i have the equation to show for it
okay so uh here's genuine science and
comparison okay science is objective its
purpose its goal is to understand how
the universe works for that you need to
you know understand gravity you need to
understand uh magnetism electricity what
the atom looks like you need to look at
you need to discover you need to try to
explain the invisible world of mother
natures and father universes you can't
it's the visible stuff with intangible
stuff that we have figured out we
haven't figured out the intangible
invisible stuff that's where the problem
is and in science we must explain and
read and uh regurgitate what the
previous generation feed us is not
science
okay
so uh let's get science right on the
right track what this fellow who was
doing was not science what what he said
is science that's not science okay here
we have uh examples of that here's uh
gravity uh according to general
relativity is this science okay we have
uh the earth and the moon flying around
it and they're both uh going around the
sun
okay and so why doesn't the earth fly
away and so the answer that these people
give you is that uh time is warped
or what this file said the other day
time is bent
okay so time is bent what are we saying
bending the seconds the minutes the
hours so we have a problem because this
is an irrational explanation that
general relativity has and which has fed
to the world this is not rational at all
so this is not an explanation it's not a
physical interpretation for how gravity
works how the universe works okay
here's a
light okay
what is light well they say it's a wave
packet okay what's a wave packet and
this is what they draw this is what they
show you this is a wave package you're
staring at it this nonsense this little
squiggly little thing that moves what is
that what are we staring at
what is this nonsense but this is the
way they they illustrate it okay and uh
just in case if you don't believe in
this you can go always to the nobel
prize winners and here's a nobel prize
winner and his name is roger penrose he
won the nobel prize the other day okay
and what did he draw he's the guy who
invented the penrose staircase by the
way and he
draws this in his book a wave packet
that's where i got it got it from his
book it's that's a way packet what is
that uh robin hood's arrow with a
squiggly whatever around it that's a
wave packet is this what light is
i mean show me the mediator of light and
they say it's a wave pack and that's
what they draw it's ridiculous
but this is what people swallow and they
say oh it's okay i have no problem with
it here's the atom okay uh this is the
one that they use the planetary model
they have uh three quarks in the center
they're
held by gluons which are bed springs
that are somehow vibrating they have
this blue electron ball going around
and it falls from one level to another
and rises from one level to another
energy levels whatever those are and um
and the question wasn't why does that
little blue ball fly away spontaneously
why does it fall to the nucleus i mean
it doesn't do either it just goes from
one level to another back and forth what
by miracle i mean what's what's the
explanation for it that's what these
people have to answer okay and no they
just feed it to you and people believe
it and they have to use that model to
explain for example electricity because
what is electricity well here it is you
see electricity also there is the
explanation it's a bunch of electron
balls okay that fly from one atom to the
next so if this is electricity you have
to rely on the planetary model which i
just showed okay and again the question
is why doesn't the electron
spontaneously fly away okay that's what
you have to answer if you cannot answer
that question you don't even have a
starting point you cannot even begin
your presentation say okay let me
explain electricity to you let me
explain ionization to you let me explain
the quantum jump to you you cannot do
any of those because you're going to
rely on the planetary model which you at
the end of your presentation say oh by
the way uh we don't believe in our own
planetary model that's not the model of
the atom then why did you use it to
explain electricity quantum jump and
you know um
ionization why did you use that model
show me the real model show me your atom
before you begin after all a lot of
people out there claim that they
photographed and filmed with the uh
atomic force microscope uh with the
scanning electron microscope they filmed
and interviewed every single electron
every proton so if that's the case you
should not be able you should not have
any excuse not to draw to illustrate for
me an atom a hydrogen atom will do all i
need is to see your little atom is it a
proton with a little electron bead next
to it is that your atom
yeah i mean you can't say well we don't
know what it looks like we've never seen
that far well you did or you did you
either filmed it and photographed it or
you did that's one issue the other one
is okay so even if you uh filmed and
photographed it just explain to me why
the electron beat doesn't fly away
that's how simple it is
and uh finally here we have magnetism
and for that we have to look at what
this fellow from ucla he's a professor
okay he's a phd okay that's what you're
gonna be listening to
and he's gonna explain how a magnet
attracts another he's gonna boast
because they know it all okay okay so
what is he gonna explain he's gonna
explain that the electrons in each
magnet
you know spin in the same direction
that's what he's gonna say
okay even if that's the case how does
that produce attraction between two
magnets or repulsion between two magnets
that's the issue so let him let's hear
him first okay you'll hear his own
version i sped it up here okay just so
that you can uh listen to it in fast
motion here it is one magnet either
repels or attracts another and nobody
knows why
except you after watching today's video
one way to understand magnets is through
magnetic domains
it was discovered that electrons had a
property called spin that is the
electron was spinning as it circled the
nucleus
it's the alignment of these electrons
spins that results in the magnetic
properties of iron these atoms have an
unusual double valence in which their
two valence electrons are paired with
parallel spins in summary a magnet is a
collection of microscopic crystal
domains that have their electron spins
aligned this is particularly prevalent
in iron nickel and cobalt in which there
is a pair of valence electrons with
their spins aligned
i like how these people are so arrogant
they know it all they know it all and
they talk about spin when first spin is
not spin
okay
uh particle is not a particle in quantum
mechanics
they use these words like particle and
spin and people say well i know what a
particle is i know what a spin is it's
like you spin a top no it ain't
the spin in quantum they don't even know
how to define it they just say it's a
property of an electron that's all they
say but then they use the word spin when
they're trying to give you an
explanation like this one they say well
it spins and you say okay i understand
what spin is no that's not what it is in
quantum mechanics spin is not like a top
spinning
okay and so they use these words and
they mislead the public
and and they mislead even the students
you know people who are going to
graduate in graduating
in quantum mechanics and whatever and so
the particle's not a particle because
it's not the classical particle it's not
a little ball which is what they
illustrate and move around then they say
well the particle's not a particle a
particle is a
wave function
what do you mean it's a wave what is the
wave function yeah it's collapsed you
know it collapsed
and then it spins what spins you mean it
twirls around no no that's not spinning
quantum what is spin oh we don't know
and so he uses spin and okay let's
concede let's concede so the electrons
are spinning in this magnet in in this
other magnet how does that attract two
magnets
and here's the analogy okay here
this is the analogy you have a wagon two
wagons really and the melons the
watermelons are spinning in the same
direction tell me how that attracts the
two carts together okay here it is
okay so you have the melon the
watermelons okay and they're spinning
okay great they're spinning in the same
direction from above you can say they're
spinning clockwise in both carts how
does that bring the two carts together
that's what i want you to tell me uh you
don't like them spinning in the same
direction okay we'll make one of them
spin in the opposite direction if that
helps at all i don't know you tell me
so how how does that bring the fact that
the watermelons you know the electrons
are spinning in each magnet how does
that uh attract or repel two magnets
what is the mechanism to say that you
know the electrons are spinning and
brings two magnets together you know you
don't have a mechanism
and so you know these people say we know
it we know they use that word no it's a
fact that we proved it
we have evidence
and then they come up with this nonsense
they say well the electrons spin in each
magnet in the same direction okay so
they spin assuming you know assuming
electrons are particles assuming they
spin none of which is true because
particles ain't particles and spin ain't
spin okay let's concede and how does
that bring the two magnets together
and yeah you can wait 100 years for it
so these people they they talk about you
know
knowledge that they know and that
they've proven through experiments that
they tested the hypothesis and then they
come up with this irrational poppycock
okay so so you tell me if they have the
right scientific method